I was looking especially for women
judges and she was one of the people
that I thought there would be ready to
be appointed to the bench and obviously
I ain't spoke to her and encouraged her
to make herself available and during the
interviews she interviewed well and if I
may say so because the deliberations
within the GSE confidential but I
obviously was one of the people who felt
that she had interviewed well and I
supported her candidature and in that
that's the role that I played but in the
end of course it was the JSC which took
the decision but as the head of that
Court I made my views heard about her
readiness
you have correct yes how did she perform
what sort of a person was she to work
with she is a compass not easily
excitable who takes her work very very
seriously and and and and she has that
correct good character of being a judge
she's a very patient person she has a
very deep listening capacity in a calm
manner she's able to deal with people
who come before her whether big or small
rich or poor literate or otherwise she
has the ability to treat people well and
she's that capacity toward us to
understand human beings and humanity
that is what I like about a I hesitate
to ask this question but I want you to
take him
hopefully the right way marrying the
mind I'm a foreigner I've been on the
outside
working in on South African watching its
history going from apartheid to
democracy and and positive
discrimination and affirmation and
trying to be more equal in its society
how much do you think her color helped
her and might influence her in her
rulings in in general in doing cases yes
III if anything at all I think and I
hope the influence would be a positive
one I should imagine I'm just thinking
loud now I should imagine that she would
have realized that she was one of the
firstly the first black judges to be
appointed as judges that in itself plays
a lot of responsibility on a because she
would say to herself there may be people
who made up my abilities simply as a
result of the color of my skin now I
want to prove them wrong so in that
sense that kind of realization would
would have would have an impact on her a
work but as I said in a positive way she
would feel inspired to say I can't
afford to fail because I'm a black
person if I fail
some critics will say AHA we told you
black people would not be able to do
this so that would that that would not
have been irrelevant entirely in a
thinking I said that would be the first
point the second one would be also that
she was a woman one of the first women
to be appointed there again a similar
she would feel a similar
responsibility or obligation visa fees
this time around not a service black
people but this time around we service
other women black and white and then she
would say to herself and one of the
first women to be appointed judges of
the High Court in this country and I
can't let women down can I ask about
this case I know you don't want to talk
specifically but the Oscar Pistorius
murder trial is very different to any
other case there's been in South African
that it's been broadcast live how do you
think a personality a person like just
receiver would have been able to cope
with that has been able to go for that I
I have no doubt in my mind that to her
even though you say that he said
peculiar case in in in because of the
fact that he's being broadcast live I
have no doubt in my mind that today it
was an ordinary case and let me say this
to you after you asked for my interview
I phoned her because I was told that she
was going to give judgment shortly
before the day on which you proposed for
to broadcasters so I was uncomfortable
about that closeness of these two events
and I asked her whether I could come for
this interview I mean or she said to me
she said to me to her that is neither
here nor there and in fact she says to
me since you started doing this trial
she reads no newspapers she watches no
TV so it's neither here no